thanks so much to the organizers for
inviting me here um it's really great to
have the opportunity um to present here
and my name is Annie Chen um I'm a
third-year computer science PhD student
here at Stanford um I'm advised by
Chelsea Finn and today I'm really
excited to present on some of my work um
single life robot deployment um adapting
on the fly to novel
scenarios so in the past few years um
we've seen a lot of amazing recent
advances in autonomous robots um
building on years of PR work um so these
are some recent demos from Google um
Toyota Research Institute and also some
of my labmates
um and so it's really exciting now we
have robots that can do tasks that would
be helpful in many settings um but
generally these still only work in
pretty controlled environments um so
what's currently preventing all of these
robots from helping out in real in the
real world um Beyond controlled
environments um so the problem is that
even equipped with prior experience and
pre-training um robots will encounter a
wide variety of um outof distribution
situations at deployment time and and
these might require a large amount of on
the-fly
adaptation um and robots often generally
like struggle um to adapt on the Fly um
to unexpected circumstances and here's
an example of this happening in the real
world so um here we have a LED robot and
this is part of the police force in New
York um they just got these and this is
from April 2023 um and I think this is a
collapsed garage so they send the robot
in to do um some sort of search and
rescue
um but as soon as it hits some
unfamiliar terrain it falls over um and
so this isn't great we uh want to avoid
things like this happening um especially
as we start to incorporate real robots
in the uh in the world
um and so the issue is um yeah the issue
here is that we can't often anticipate
every possible test scenario um for
example so on the previous slide a Sean
rescue robot May encounter novel
obstacles while traversing a building um
a robot exploring on Mars looking for
water will have to uh contend with some
unknown terrain probably um and a
household robot cleaning up a new spill
might have to pick up an unfamiliar
bull so I'm really interested in how can
we get robots that adapt on the fly at
deployment
time now in principle reinforcement
learning provides a framework for
allowing robots to adapt autonomously um
from their own
experience but currently in practice um
it doesn't work to just take these
algorithms and apply them during
deployment um to have robots that adapt
on the Fly and this is because of um
several different challenges with this
approach so standard RL algorithms often
need a lot of feedback in the form of
some reward function um and it's often
difficult to construct a a dense reward
um for especially for like unseen
situations um and these methods often
also need to be able to retry the task
um many times in order to learn how to
complete it and so this often requires
human intervention to come in and reset
the robot over and over again and also
um a lot of reinforcement learning
algorithms learn from scratch um and we
really want to build towards um lifelong
agents that can leverage prior
experience um um so that they can adapt
on the fly from what they um already
know so an alternative Paradigm is reset
free reinforcement learning um where
instead of having a human come and reset
the robot um the robot actually
practices both learning the task and
learning to undo the task so it can like
keep practicing without human
interventions um however this is um a
step in the right direction but we
really want a paradigm that f focuses on
adapting to new unseen scenarios um and
also better leverages its prior
experience so we introduce a third
Paradigm um and we call it single life
reinforcement learning um in hopes that
it may better reflect these challenges
so in this setting the agent is given
some prior experience and maybe it can
even already do the task to some degree
but then it encounters an out of
distribution or a new scenario at test
time and it must adapt to to solve that
task without any human interventions or
supervision um and it needs to figure
out how to do the handle the situation
um within a single episode um and so
that's why we call it single
life
so um as an instantiation of single life
ARL um here the agent has been given
prior knowledge on how to run in an
environment with no obstacles and we
evaluate its ability to adapt in a
single episode to an environment with
obstacles um so well we might just try
to run reinforcement learning at test
time in order to adapt to these
obstacles um but here as you can see
when the agent makes a mistake and it
falls out of distribution it can no
longer rely on resets to recover so what
happens is that the agent the algorithm
like will just get stuck and it won't be
able to handle this scenario um so
existing reinforcement learning
algorithms really don't allow us to have
um robots that actually adapt on the fly
during deployment and overall I think
this is a generally really interesting
problem there's a lot of room for
Progress um and so one idea that we've
had towards um this problem is to have
robots not just adapt in the lowlevel
space of actions but also adapt in the
space of behaviors to figure out how to
handle um a novel scenario um at
deployment time so in particular if the
robot has some pre-trained behaviors
like it knows how to walk slide Crouch
um could we get um it to handle new
scenarios more efficiently by adapting
in the space of these
behaviors so given some pre-trained
behaviors um then within a single
episode test time we want a robot to be
able to handle like typical conditions
but also to be able to handle slippery
conditions maybe it accidentally damages
its leg um in the middle of deployment
and so on and all of these are things
that it might not have seen during
training um and our hope is that maybe
it can handle these conditions better um
by trying different behaviors that it
knows and modulating between
them um so now there's like a rich
definitely a rich body of work that does
um look at how to combine prior
behaviors to solve long Horizon tasks um
for example hierarchical um
reinforcement learning and um so many of
these train a highle policy um that
learns to choose behaviors but but um
the issu is that giv getting such a
policy often requires an additional
online training phase and this may need
a lot of online samples to learn um so
this isn't effective for learning to
adapt quickly within um a single life so
is there a way that we can quickly
figure out which behaviors are relevant
at each time
step um we propose a method called
robust automous modulation or real and
the key observation is to Leverage The
expressive power of each Behavior's
value function to guide this selection
um value functions inherently contain um
detailed information about potential
rewards associated with different states
for each behavior um so for a given
Behavior it can um if it can likely
succeed in that scenario um the value
function at that State should be pretty
high so this means that at each um time
step during the single life if we choose
one of the behaviors with a high value
at the current state um perhaps that
will lead us to handle the novelty and
solve the task and since we already have
access to value functions from
pre-training the behaviors um this
approach doesn't require any additional
training or data
collection the issue is um uh naively
using pre-trained value functions may
not lead to high reward behaviors and
this is because um these pre-trained
value functions tend to overestimate in
out of distribution States and um we
don't want this because we don't want
one of the behaviors mistakenly giving a
high value to a state just because it's
never seen it
before so with the um existing prior
data from each Behavior we're going to
do an initial fine-tuning step um to
correct this and fine-tune the value
functions with an additional loss that
minimizes overestimation of the values
at States um for which a different
behavior is
better so specifically we have um the
standard Bellman error on the left and
then We additionally add a cross entropy
loss between the softmax of the values
of the behaviors and the behavior index
from which that state um was visited so
what what this does is it just um it
trains each Behavior to separate in
value um between states that it visits
versus ones that other behaviors visit
um so it pushes up the value for states
that are visited um by that behavior and
then pushes down for states that are
visited by other behaviors um in in this
way the value functions are then less
likely to overestimate at unfamiliar
States and then once we have these um
fine-tuned value functions for each of
our behaviors at test time we'll sample
a behavior from the softmax distribution
um given by the behaviors values at that
current state and then EX an action um
from that behavior update and then that
behavior with fine tuning and then move
on to the next time step um where we can
repeat this selection process um and
importantly we can yeah update that
behavior with fine-tuning so we're able
to um both adapt at each time Step At
The behavior level but then also we can
fine-tune the parameters of individual
behaviors um so our selection mechanism
um quickly identifies appropriate
behaviors in a given situation um so
this circum vets the need to learn a
separate highlevel controller or
adaptation module um and this approach
is also agnostic to how the policies and
value functions of the prior behaviors
are trained um and it can potentially
provide improvements in new situations
with either a small or large number of
um pre-trained behaviors and then
finally um the adaptation process all
happens within a single episode at test
time to um a variety of situations
instead of learning how to adapt across
many
episodes um we have some theory in the
paper on why the additional cross
entropy loss helps but I'm just um think
it gets into the nitty-gritty so skip
that
um H so how does a real compareed to
Prior methods um so in simulation we
started with a simulated go1 a quadraped
robot um and we evaluate two separate
things varying joint stiffness and
varying um
friction and we evaluate the number of
steps to succeed in the single life so
um the lower the number the
better we compared to a state-of-the-art
fine-tuning method rlpd um a
state-of-the-art metaal method RMA um as
well as using a highle classifier to uh
predict the
skills um so for the stiffness
evaluation on the left um the
pre-trained skills that it has
corresponds to having um different
joints that are frozen during training
but then at test time a new joint is
frozen and then um for the friction
there's skills that were trained with
one of the four feet having low friction
and then at test time the friction of
one or two of the feet is changed to be
lower than anything that was seen during
training um so first looking at the
these prior methods both rlpd
fine-tuning and RMA struggle especially
in the stiffness setting um on the left
the bars are really high um again Lower
bars is better here um so that
demonstrates the um importance in this
evaluation um setting especially of
adapting in the space of behaviors
rather than um just the space of actions
for more efficient adaptation um and uh
hlc struggles especially um in the
friction eval Suite on the right and
then this may be because it um doesn't
take into account the value of the
behavior at a given state it only takes
into account um State visitation
frequency um and then we evaluate Rome
which is um shown in the rightmost bar
in Orange um as well as Rome noof which
is an ablation that um doesn't use the
additional cross entropy loss that I
mentioned um so especially in the
dynamic friction eval um having the
additional crossentropy termine the loss
function is really important to
encourage better Behavior selection in
different regions of the state
space and um overall for Rome we're able
to get um over 2x um faster adaptation
so it's able to get to the goal twice uh
um yeah twice as fast compared to the
best other
approach and so um Can this actually
work on a real robot um so we got a go
one and pre-trained um behaviors walking
with um different legs Frozen and then
we looked at three different test scaras
that were pretty different from anything
that it saw during training um so the
first scenario that we looked at was to
put roller skates on the front two feet
of um the quadruped and if you just
evaluate the walking policy it basically
Falls over immediately um and really
isn't able to handle this distribution
shift um uh if you try using like
something like a highle classifier this
also struggles to get anywhere um and
then this is with r and so we see that
even though this scenario is super out
of distribution compared to what it was
trained on um it's able to adapt within
this single episode actually um and so
it actually enables the robot to slide
forward on roller skates without ever
wearing them um doing training
um we also looked at some other
scenarios like carrying heavy luggage so
here a case of um heavy lugage is tied
to the back left leg of the robot and
again the robot is able to bring It
Forward even though it didn't see any
luggage during training and this is um
corresponds to about 13 lbs um and then
in this last CER we um started with the
heavy luggage and then
um Midway through we um removed the
backpack which is actually quite heavy
and so you see that the robot is
actually um speeding up here a little
bit um and so it's able to handle like
these Dynamic changing payloads um and
it's able to continue pulling even when
we put on um another
backpack yeah so it can pull heavy
luggage um and pull Dynamic um payloads
without ever pulling any object before
um and so across these three situations
um we measured the average time and
number of Falls to completion um and
Rome significantly outperforms um using
a high level classifier as well as the
Baseline walking policy um and although
none of the prior behaviors are trained
to um specifically handle these test
time scenarios um the robot can leverage
parts of each relevant Behavior to
actually still complete the task um so
in these scenarios like um figuring out
how to quickly modulate in the space of
behaviors um and also
balancing modulating in the space of
behaviors with um low-level adaptation
provides a mechanism for um single life
test time adaptation um to unseen
situations um yeah so I'm really excited
about um single life deployment it
provides a natural setting in which to
study autonomous robot adaptation to
novel situations and Rome is a simple
algorithm for autonomous deployment time
um this uh sort of
adaptation um yeah so thanks to my
wonderful collaborators and uh my
adviser Chelsea Finn um and thanks again
to the organizers for inviting me um and
yeah happy to get to U present my work
here um and happy to take any
questions go ahead okay so for the all
three conditions they are all
pre-trained with like assuming some LS
or froz is that correct yeah yeah so we
um we were just trying out like how well
uh the um just with what sort of
different behaviors um what sort of like
adaptation we could get um and uh so we
um did pretty much the simplest thing
which was just train walking and then
train walking with like different um
legs Frozen um and I think there's a lot
of um interesting ways to um explore and
extend on um what happens when you have
like access to different sorts of
behaviors yeah is there like any other
conditions y'all be thinking about like
pre-training the robot with like other
than having a few L broen yeah yeah so
actually one thing that we are exploring
right now is like um really trying to um
start with better pre-trained Behavior
so starting with like um jumping and um
crouching and um yeah those sorts of
things too um and seeing how far we can
actually get the system to adapt
there can you kind of like re explain
what the difference between like the
dynamic friction and dynamic what the
other one was yeah yeah so um in the
dynamic friction Suite it um we just the
it just refers to like different um
evaluations where we're um testing um uh
where we train uh pre-trained behaviors
and then evaluate test time um and so
stiffness we just um keep one joint um
stiff at test time so um our initial uh
inspiration for this was thinking about
how um maybe a robot might get damaged
in the middle of um its deployment and
maybe it might not be able to like use a
joint or something um and so being able
to adapt to that and then um but we
couldn't actually damage a robot just to
see um and then friction was just um
trying uh different um friction with the
feet all right I I don't know if this is
relevant at all from the bio inspired
side there's been studies of daddy balln
spiders which apparently not rarely will
lose one or even two
legs and there must be some L Jal
Behavior because they can sort of manage
right away but by the end of the day
they're walking much better wow yeah
that's super
cool cool all right thanks again thank
you so
[Applause]
much